hi there and thanks for joining in this
sample I will demonstrate how to create
a simple Drupal developer portal for
your apogee API product let's get
started apogee's Drupal developer portal
is a highly customizable solution where
developers can discover learn about and
test your apis like the integrated
developer portal it serves as the
central hub for your API consumers but
unlike the integrated developer portal
the Drupal portal isn't managed directly
within apogee now before we begin this
accelerator sample be sure to read the
intro sections and note the
prerequisites you'll be able to follow
along the instructions either in Cloud
shell or right here in this repository
in this video we'll follow along with
Cloud shell
so without further Ado click on the
cloud shell button this will download
the apogee samples GitHub repository
code directly into your Cloud shell
editor
once the repository is loaded into your
Cloud shell
CD into the correct folder
if needed you can ensure that you're
assigned into the correct account with
this command
next update the environment file with
your own apogee information
then Source your environment file
now this is where it gets interesting
run this command to deploy the API proxy
and product note however that this
command will not create your developer
portal we will need to do that
separately
once that finishes we will navigate to
the next page and follow the
instructions there
now we need to launch the Drupal portal
in a new tab enter the gcp project where
your apogee organization is deployed and
navigate to Cloud Marketplace
once there search for apogee developer
portal kickstart
and enter the solution
click launch once you're inside
configure a portal with the name of
sample Drupal developer portal and
select a Zone near your apogee
organization
you may need to create a new service
account for the portal and be sure that
you enable https under networking
all other settings can be left at
default values
once you're done click deploy
this will start a deployment manager
deployment and should take about an hour
to complete
from within your deployment manager
Drupal deployment page you'll find your
https link along with your basic off
credentials on the right once the
deployment is complete make note of the
credentials and enter the https site
enter the credentials
now we need to install the Drupal
content and finish its configuration
choose your language and click save and
continue
give it a minute to install the site
configure the endpoint to reflect apogee
X and paste in your apogee org ID click
save configuration
configure your site with the name sample
Drupal developer portal and register
your own account as the site email
address also Grant your account admin
access to the portal once that's done
click save and continue
go ahead and install the Drupal content
and click save and continue again give
it a minute and you'll arrive at the
home page of your Drupal developer
portal
comes pre-configured with demo content
but feel free to ignore that as none of
it is relevant to this video or your
apogee organization
the first thing you'll want to do within
the portal is make sure that you are
signed into your admin account if you
aren't be sure to sign in
the next thing we want to do is add our
apogee product to the Drupal API catalog
so from the home page navigate to
content and then to API catalog
click the Plus open API button for name
enter sample Drupal developer portal API
also enter a description
for the specification Source type use
the Drupal developerportal.yaml file
from the cloud shell repo so navigate
back to Cloud shell select the file and
download it
upload the Drupal
developerportal.yaml file as API
documentation
leave all other fields as their default
values and click save
the final configuration step is to
create an app so we can access a secured
Drupal developer portal API that we just
created so navigate to apps from the top
nav bar next click the add app button
name your new app sample Drupal
developer portal app leave the Callback
URL blank as well as the description and
finally make sure that sample Drupal
developer portal product is selected
before clicking add app now we're ready
to test our API within your new sample
Drupal developer Portal app copy the
consumer key this key can also be known
as the API key once you have that
navigate to the apis page from the top
nav bar
find your sample Drupal developer portal
API and click into it
from within the API click authorize and
enter your consumer key
after that select the slash get method
and from under try this API click the
execute button
voila a 200 response means that it was
successful you now have a working API
secured and documented within your
Drupal developer portal
now optionally you can clean up and
delete the resources that we created in
this video
first navigate to the apogee console
next go to the developers page find the
account that you created in your Drupal
developer portal hover over it and
select the trash can icon to delete this
will also delete all apogee apps
associated with your developer next
navigate to the gcp deployment manager
from your Drupal deployment click delete
at the top a pop-up will be shown
select the option to delete all
resources associated with the Drupal
portal
lastly go back to the cloud shell and
run the cleanup script to delete all
resources that our deploy script created
at the beginning of this sample video
thanks for watching I hope this video
was useful to you if you have not signed
up for apogee yet use the top link if
you have any questions please visit the
apogee Community thank you